[Music]
well safety set is actually a line set
that I used to prick fingers for micro
blood samples it's widely used in
hospital diabetic patients need them for
daily dose lab monitoring and there's a
white complains of the picking pains of
other landset especially traditional
answer there are many steps of process
before you use a Lancer so safety set is
designed to reduce pain and remove fear
from the end-user we have a technology
breakthrough in a firing mechanism you
use a safety set and compared of the
legs and you can feel that there is no
southern search of false how to
activation and we also have what the
smallest return in the market that is
easy for you every around and another
features that we have a smallest gaming
area using high quality genomic needle
which is designed for contact evasions
so whoever who use it will have a very
consistent click I went through a long
process of thinking
took me five years Volvo's to come up to
a final design to counter all the
complaints feedbacks from end user
because end users should wear so it's
very important and TAS will give you
the best design that you want for your
product
[Music]